[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on interroge le public sur notre
invité je crois qu'il dirait qu'il est
un éternel adolescent un homme qui sera
toujours jeune branchée insouciant et
même un brin siphonné sa folie sa
légèreté c'est ce qu'il nous montre
peut-être pour dissimuler sa timidité ou
sa sensibilité on verra ça avec lui car
il est aussi écrivain acteur réalisateur
et bien sûr animateur et producteur de
télévision il a fait la grande époque de
canal les images qu'on a de lui et qui
resteront dans les annales ce sont ses
sketchs avec José Garcia provoquant les
fous rires mémorables et s'y attachants
de Philippe Gildas sur le plateau de
nulle part ailleurs ce sont aussi ces
discours d'introduction ironique et ses
transitions pleine de sarcasme lors des
cérémonies des Césars il nous laisse pas
seulement de l'image il nous laisse
aussi du son celui de sa voix et de son
débit si particulier celui du rock aussi
sa passion absolue pas une interview en
lui parle pas à des Beatles ou de Bruce
Springsteen mais son amour pour la
culture anglo-saxonne ne l'a pas empêché
de faire son tour de France à lui avec
la Gaule d'Antoine une émission où il
revisite la France des territoires et ça
ça nous parle au Sénat les territoires
qu'a-t-il appris dans ce tour des
régions que retient-il de ses rencontres
posant lui toutes ces questions
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenu Antoine de Caunes merci d'être
avec nous ici au Sénat dans ce dôme
Tournon le Sénat un lieu où le mot
territoire est presque sacré j'ai envie
de dire le Sénat c'est la chambre des
territoires comment vous l'avez trouvé
cette France que vous avez revisitée
c'est qu'on avait d'abord quand je dis
on sait pas un on Louis XIV c'est avec
mon partenaire oui Peter Stewart qui est
un Américain qui vit à Los Angeles avec
qui je travaille depuis 35 ans
maintenant avec un effet rapido
du retrache en Angleterre plein de
choses et on avait fait une série de
documentaires sur des grandes villes à
travers le monde avec pour pour postulat
de départ de faire une visite qui ce qui
échappe au côté patrimonial classique
avec tous les tous les poncis habituels
de ce genre d'émission mais d'aller de
faire un pas de côté et d'aller voir des
gens qui qui envisagent la vie autrement
qui
une collection de portraits qui mise en
scène
finit par composer un vrai tableau de
alors de la ville à l'époque
et des régions après après avoir fait le
tour de pas mal de villes pendant une
dizaine d'années on s'est fait la
réflexion qu'en fait on avait traité pas
mal d'endroits mais jamais la France
alors on s'est dit on va faire une
mission sur Paris n'est pas la France
vous la prends pas
et donc on a poussé la réflexion un peu
plus loin et on s'est dit qu'on allait
faire une collection
sur les régions de France
que j'y ai découvert
en fait c'est que c'est un pays assez
extraordinaire la France avec des gens
vraiment originaux marrants et quand
vous quand vous déplacez et que vous
alliez je sais pas du fin fond du Pays
Basque lors de l'Alsace évidemment il y
a toujours des particularités
culturelles régionales mais vous avez
quand vous les cherchez une collection
j'insiste sur le mot de gens qui qui ont
des initiatives étranges originales
on a toujours tendance à tout niveler
c'est à dire que voilà la France est un
pays avec un esprit une culture en fait
c'est plein de petits pays la France
avec un lien fort qui est l'idée de la
nation mais mais vraiment
j'ai eu l'impression de voyager aussi
loin en allant en France que quand je
suis allé au Japon ou en Angleterre et
quel accueille on vous a réservé vous
celui qu'on peut qualifier de Parisiens
branchés c'est un peu l'image que vous
véhiculez ce qui n'est peut-être pas la
bonne d'ailleurs mais comment vous
accueilli bah écoutez plutôt bien parce
qu'en fait le
j'ai la chance d'avoir laissé une bonne
impression aux gens qui qui regardaient
la télé à l'époque que vous évoquiez il
y a quelques instants et donc c'est on
est toujours plutôt bien accueilli que
quand on a on a pratiquement fait partie
des meubles à une époque on était dans
dans le salon des gens donc on était
dans le foyer on était un meuble qui
bougeait et qui
faisait rire qui redonner un peu
d'humeur et de légèreté le soir enfin de
journée et donc ils ont gardé ce bon
souvenir là donc
j'ai toujours été bien accueilli quoi
et puis comme c'est une télévision alors
là exactement le contraire de celle-ci
où là on est au cœur de Paris on peut
pas être plus au cœur de Paris avec cet
endroit extraordinaire
mais vous vous recevez des gens moi
j'allais chez eux je les fais de
cueillir des gens sur des plateaux je
l'ai fait pendant des années j'ai pris
beaucoup de plaisir à le faire mais
c'est une c'est très très différent
quand en fait vous allez voir les gens
chez eux dans leur biotope que vous les
mettez à l'aise que vous passez des
heures avec eux donc ça se résume pas
une petite interview entre entre deux
portes comme ça et vous obtenez des
choses absolument étonnantes et
magnifiques c'est intéressant que vous
disiez ça parce que j'ai retenu en
préparant cette émission cette citation
de vous dans le monde vous dites partir
en reportage c'est vraiment ce que je
préfère au monde je ne suis plus du tout
à l'aise sur un plateau télé quoi parce
que je l'ai fait que je ne supporte plus
ça tout simplement alors il y a plateau
et plateau il y a il y a les plateaux
type profession qui émission que j'ai
fait parlant de trois ans à canal ou
vraiment
réunissez autour d'une table pour parler
mais pour parler d'un coeur de métier et
en évacuant tout le côté promo habituel
donc ça changeait quand même énormément
la nature des propos
cette ça j'aime bien mais enfin on se
rapproche de la radio là simplement
c'est mis en image c'est comme ce qu'on
est en train de faire en ce moment mais
la télé de plateau avec le plateau les
gens qui applaudissent les interruptions
toutes les 7 minutes pour la pub ou pour
envoyer des
magnétosité dérangé par le concept
qu'est ce qui vous a fatigué
je m'amuse plus du tout à faire ça je me
suis amusé un certain temps mais c'est
fini c'est superficiel
on se raconte pas grand-chose en fait on
se raconte pas grand chose on est
toujours il faut aller à l'essentiel
enfin à l'essentiel on est dans une
espèce de faux urgence comme ça parce
qu'il y a le direct parce qu'il y a la
pression il y a les autres émissions
autour
ça m'intéresse plus du tout ça avec
potentiellement une culture du buzz une
culture du clash
[Musique]
continuons sur cette question j'ai
regardé la liste de toutes les émissions
de télé auquel vous aviez participé de
près ou de loin elle est interminable
donc je vais pas évidemment tout citer
ça peut prêter la confusion bon en tout
cas c'est
ce sont les émissions ça veut juste dire
que vous votre carrière a été riche
télévision vous voyez c'est mieux dit
comme ça ça a commencé avec chorus en
709 sur Antenne 2 toujours autour du
rock il y a eu houba houba rapido vous
participez on l'a dit au début de canal
avec nulle part ailleurs il y a eu aussi
euro trash sur channel for Le Grand
Journal émission d'Antoine bref j'en
passe quelle est l'aventure qui est qui
a été pour vous la plus gonflée la plus
audacieuse et vous sentez que vous ne
pourriez pas la refaire aujourd'hui ce
serait impossible
je crois pas je crois pas trop à ça moi
en fait je crois qu'on peut on peut
faire plein de choses et que
les enfin pour moi l'aventure la plus
excitante c'est celle que je vais celle
qui arrive
je me retourne jamais vers le vers le
passé j'ai aucune nostalgie
après je pense que toutes les émissions
des particularités la toute première
qu'en russes c'était une émission
c'est vrai j'aime beaucoup le rock on
parlait uniquement de rock à une époque
où personne d'autre en parlait le
transmettiez des concerts
la musique à l'époque était occupée par
les plateaux par Michel Sardou Claude
François et Dalida qui avait c'est une
alternative donc c'était quelque chose
de très très excitant à l'époque à faire
mais comme nulle part ailleurs était une
émission super excitante à faire parce
que c'était le premier talk show en fait
c'était la matrice des talk shows en
France inspiré de ce que vous avez des
Américains évidemment et donc il y avait
tout un terrain à défricher à découvrir
des bornes à poser et puis une
insouciance aussi liée à l'époque est-ce
qu'il y avait liberté qu'il n'y a plus
aujourd'hui
n'étaient pas relu
liberté absolue mais c'était
aussi assez expérimental c'est un
laboratoire cette chaîne au départ
c'est-à-dire on avait on avait pour
mission de mettre en place une chaîne de
télévision qui soit une alternative à ce
qui se passait ailleurs donc il
s'agissait pas de reproduire ce que
faisait des autres et ce qu'on avait
fait nous-mêmes sur d'autres chaînes
précédemment mais d'essayer d'inventer
d'inventer un format sachant que les
arguments de vente de la chaîne c'était
le cinéma le sport et les films de
boules
nous on avait une émission en clair dans
le fameux Access et avec pour mission
en fait moi j'ai grandi là dedans parce
que j'ai grandi dans une famille de
services publics l'idée c'était de
d'informer de divertir voilà les deux
étant intimement liés donc on a essayé
de faire ça pendant quelques années on
recevait des invités puis on déconnait
avec eux on s'amusait vous alliez loin
parfois parce qu'évidemment là aussi
pour préparer la mission j'ai regardé un
nouveau quelques sketchs et quelques-uns
de vos personnages avec José Garcia dont
je parlais en introduction ce duo
absolument loufoque et grinçant dont on
doit vous parler tout le temps j'ai
retenu Didier l'embrouille j'ai le gros
paquet Gérard langue de avec
parfois même des moments de gêne en
plateau on a revu les archives avec
l'invité Philippe Labro on sent qu'il y
a une petite gêne ça vous fait rire
quand j'en parle est-ce que vous êtes
déjà fait engueuler après un SketchUp
quand même on n'est pas là à se faire
gourmander parce qu'on aurait dit on
aurait poussé le bouchon trop loin non
non ça existe pas ça au contraire on
avait des mêmes des patrons l'escure et
de greffe qui nous encouragaient
allez-y amusez-vous après la la
l'auto-censure naturelle qui se mettait
en place toute seule c'est que moi mon
attention c'est pas du tout de blesser
des invités les heurter ou qui
ressortent du plateau en disant vraiment
il a abusé de la situation
c'est facile d'abuser de la situation
quand vous êtes en direct vous êtes chez
vous vous
donc c'est pas du tout ma nature était
bonne finalement ça n'était pas mal pris
oui l'idée c'était toujours de rire avec
et de pas rire contre moi j'ai jamais
victimisé mais mes invités si jamais
acharné sur eux c'est je trouve ça
absolument indigne comme comme
comportement donc on riait avec eux
alors parfois il y en a qui riait plus
puisque nous
et aujourd'hui c'est quoi votre style en
télé qu'est-ce que vous regardez comme
émission télé est-ce que vous en
regardez encore d'ailleurs
je sais que ça fait toujours un peu
posthur de dire ça quand on fait de la
télé mais je regarde pas la télé je la
regarde pas parce que très simplement
quand j'étais môme j'ai grandi dans une
famille de télévision mon père et ma
mère travaillait à la télévision en
faisait tous les deux et donc c'était
très déconseillé d'avoir c'est un objet
rare à l'époque il y a moins de d'image
en circulation et de télé qu'aujourd'hui
mais c'était rationné pour moi j'ai le
droit de regarder
quand mes parents étaient à la télé
j'ai vu je des images de mon père en
train de présenter le 20H j'ai des
images de ma mère en train de présenter
son émission rendez-vous avec mais sinon
je regardais essentiellement tirer la
fronde moi et Zorro
le dimanche soir encore un mot quand
même de votre style à vous à la
télévision de votre marque de fabrique
c'est quand même
la mise à distance la dérision l'ironie
est-ce que c'est une manière justement
de mettre à distance ce monde qui vous
paraît pas forcément à la hauteur ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'il y a derrière ça je
parlais de timidité de sensibilité en
début en introduction est-ce que c'est
un peu ça finalement cette ironie qui
masque ce que vous êtes vraiment
je suis de naturel plutôt réservé aussi
paradoxal que ça puisse vous paraître
vous rendez compte oui mais alors j'ai
beaucoup d'amis acteurs
de cinéma de théâtre et tous vous diront
la même chose c'est à dire que de ils ne
sont pas leurs personnages et il y a un
moment où en revanche quand on ouvre la
porte et qu'on devient le personnage là
il y a plus de limite et moi j'ai
toujours le sentiment de jouer des rôles
c'est à dire c'était moi sans être moi
j'étais
représentation mais y compris quand vous
êtes maître de cérémonie ou
animateur d'une émission
vous êtes là sans être c'est pas tout à
fait vous même qui est en train de me
parler là
en représentation vous êtes en train de
faire votre travail vous avez organisé
un entretien vous savez exactement où
vous allez vous voulez aller non pas moi
heureusement mais donc c'est un
personnage mais après avec des
une intensité plus ou moins grande c'est
vrai quand vous partez totalement en
vrille moi j'ai pas de limite en fait je
m'en fous une fois que je suis dans une
convention de jeux le ciel est limite
dans votre vie il y a le cinéma
effectivement alors en tant qu'acteur ça
commence dès 1989 je crois avec le rôle
principal du film de Tony Marshall qui
s'appelle pentymento comme ça qu'on dit
à partir de là vous consacrez quasiment
pleinement au cinéma et là moi ça
m'intéressait parce que je me dis
comment on passe de l'un à l'autre
comment on passe de l'humoriste de
plateau au jeu d'acteurs où vous dites
effectivement c'est quand même très
différent comment vous avez fait est-ce
que vous avez été impressionné est-ce
que ça a été difficile
c'était déjà c'était un désir de ma part
c'est à dire que je voulais moi j'aime
bien arrêter les choses à temps c'est à
dire j'ai arrêté de faire de la
télévision avec nulle part ailleurs
parce que j'avais fait le tour du sujet
quoi septembre quotidienne ça vous
fatigue un homme d'accord mais le cinéma
il faut en être capable quand même le
cinéma alors j'ai toujours été très
cinéphile j'ai toujours adoré le cinéma
j'ai toujours rêvé d'être comédien
ce que je n'étais pas du tout donc j'ai
commencé j'ai eu la chance de croiser la
route de Tony Marshall dont c'était le
premier film et
j'ai beaucoup j'ai eu beaucoup de
réserves au départ en lui disant mais je
je peux pas faire ça je peux pas jouer
il m'a dit fais-moi confiance on va
travailler on a fait effectivement 6
mois de préparation ensemble on se
voyait tous les jours à travailler le
les plus élémentaires la technique
qu'est-ce que vous faites de vos mains
de vos jambes comment vous parlez
comment vous respirez comment vous vous
moduler comment comment vous abordez une
scène
elle a senti quelque chose
j'ai eu beaucoup beaucoup de plaisir à
faire ça quoi je vais vous montrer un
document alors en l'occurrence il y en a
trois petits alors j'espère que vous
allez réussir à lire en tout cas le
public arrivera à le lire ils ont été
prêtés par nos partenaires les Archives
nationales et ça va nous emmener sur un
autre thème vous allez vite comprendre
ce sont trois projets d'affiches pour la
première fête de la musique qui ne
portait pas encore son nom définitif
document qui viennent du bureau de
Christian du pavillon conseiller
technique de Jack Lang l'événement créé
le 21 juin 82 a d'abord failli être fixé
aux 24 juin c'est ce qu'on voit sur ses
affiches il a failli s'appeler musique
dans la rue musique deux points la
France a du talent nuit de la musique
libre finalement ce sera beaucoup plus
simple ça va s'appeler la fête de la
musique ils ont eu raison ou pas
vous lui
dans votre vie c'est le rock qui vous
permet d'ailleurs de faire vos premiers
pas à la télévision avec chorus première
émission consacrée au rock et vous avez
dit à l'époque le choix c'était la
grosse variété pourrie Dalida Mireille
Mathieu qui squattait l'antenne ou bien
Herbert von Cayenne chez Chancel entre
les deux toute cette musique qui
concernait une génération silence totale
aujourd'hui c'est le télé crochet je
sais pas si c'est beaucoup mieux je sais
pas s'il y a eu des progrès
non mais en fait ce qui était très très
inquiétant à l'époque c'est que on parle
là de 78 78 vous aviez eu toute la bride
pop des années 60 Xavier l'époque
l'after punk la new wave qui qui
démarrait donc des mouvements massifs
quand même c'est à dire que c'est on
parle pas d'une d'une musique marginale
qui concerne une secte
une musique qui était devenue une
musique des plus populaires et plus
populaire au monde et qui n'avait aucun
droit de citer à la télévision à
l'époque ce qui me semblait totalement
extravagant et effectivement
on avait en boucle tout le top 50 de la
variété française qu'est-ce qui vous
plaît tant que ça dans le rock c'est
quoi c'est une sonorité c'est un style
c'est une ambiance c'est une musique qui
réveille les époques qu'est-ce qui pour
pour les gens qui ne serait pas sensible
à la musique rock et elles sont
nombreuses des on peut parler de deux
camps il y a le conque le quand il hop
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui si vous deviez
convaincre quelqu'un moi par exemple que
le rock est une musique doit s'écouter
c'est une musique merveilleuse moi qui
qui personnellement m'a ouvert beaucoup
de chakras
j'ai grandi avec ça en fait j'ai c'est
marrant parce que j'en parlais la
semaine dernière j'ai je me suis
retrouvé par hasard à l'un des concerts
des Beatles à l'Olympia en 64 j'étais
tout gamin j'étais amené là par la fille
d'un ami de mon père qui venait voir
Sylvie Vartan je me suis retrouvé là et
vraiment j'ai eu un
c'est pas du tout une impression
rétrospective le grand ça s'est passé je
me suis retrouvé devant cette espèce de
bloc d'énergie d'électricité de bonne
humeur de c'était fantastique ça m'a
ouvert
parce que c'était c'était des guillets
qui étaient en vogue à ce moment-là et
les Beatles ont été la porte
d'ouvertures peut réveiller les époques
peut réveiller des générations
aujourd'hui par exemple vous diriez que
la France est un peu endormie et que
l'Europe pourrait la réveiller c'est le
hip-hop
qui est devenu le téléchargement
non le rock est une musique de boomer
maintenant
quand vous allez quand les Stones se
passent à Paris comme mycartney passe à
Paris quand Springsteen va passer à
Paris c'est des meute donc il y a ça
concerne beaucoup de gens et puis je
pense que ce qui est c'est d'avoir
l'avantage d'une musique est très
transgénérationnelle qui qui a plu au
grand-parents maintenant
vos parents aux enfants moi je sais que
mes enfants et petits enfants écoutent
beaucoup de beaucoup de rock mais je les
ai un peu guidés dans les dans les choix
ils avaient pas intérêt à aimer le
hip-hop
rien de me dérange oui mais tout ce que
vous voulez mais en matière de rock je
peux je peux être atterrissable pendant
des journées entières votre goût pour la
musique vous vient aussi de vos parents
je crois votre père adorait l'opéra et
votre mère avait ses artistes aussi et
la Fitzgerald je crois Serge Gainsbourg
Charles Trenet aussi la comédie musicale
elle adorait la comédie musicale elle
adorait traînait elle adorait elle
faisait une mission avec les les auteurs
compositeurs français de l'époque qui
étaient qui tenaient bien là-bas et je
sais pas les les Maurice fanons les
brelles les
[Musique]
enfin bon plein de gens et mon père lui
n'écoutait que de l'Opéra pratiquement
que de l'opéra est très naît traîné à
cause des origines narbonnaises et le
virus traînait s'est transmis de
génération en génération on va peut-être
écouter un morceau on en a préparé un
pour vous vous allez sûrement
reconnaître et vous allez nous dire de
quel morceau il s'agit est-ce qu'on peut
[Musique]
l'appel complainte c'est ça exactement
de la terre ça les jours de repassage
dans la
bonne en plus c'est une des chansons les
plus surréalistes de traînais il avait
été très marqué
le texte est sublime
ça ne veut rien dire ça veut dire
beaucoup de choses et surtout ça laisse
une liberté d'interprétation à celui qui
écoute qui est infini c'est une musique
qui m'a ému quand j'avais 10 ans qui
c'est comme quand vous relisez
Monte-Cristo à chaque fois c'est un
nouveau roman et traîné je ferai écouter
la folle complainte et à chaque fois j'y
reste
musiciens batteur je crois que vous avez
votre groupe qui s'appelait les wahou
baby
ouais mais j'étais vraiment des pires
batteurs du monde pourquoi parce que je
faisais partie de ces batteur qui
ralentissent le groupe au lieu de le
pousser donc pendant que je jouais les
musiciens avec lesquels je j'avais fait
le groupe se retournait vers moi en
disant
et je me plantais assez souvent sur les
roulements
une catastrophe et comme l'époque était
à l'époque au solo de guitare ossolo de
batterie c'était très en vogue je
faisais évidemment mon solo quand on
jouait en public et d'un seul mot qui
avait pour particularité de vider la
salle les gens se barrer quoi
j'ai des photos à vous montrer je vais
pas jouer de la musique
j'ai une première photo vous avez dit
vous-même que vous étiez très
anglo-saxons dans votre approche le
portrait d'Elisabeth II qui est décédé
lui septembre 2022 je vous la oui ah bon
c'est raisons je crois qu'on est
personne n'est passé à côté de cette
information
vous qui êtes justement si anglo-saxon
si anglophile est-ce que vous allez vous
avez été touché par cette disparition
est-ce que vous avez été touché par
l'émotion des Britanniques est-ce que
oui alors moins que Stéphane Bern je
vous cache pas mais oui c'est un en fait
ce qui est assez marrant la famille
royale je trouve ça très marrant très
très kit très et en même temps c'est un
lien en Angleterre c'est un lien très
fort c'est une identité c'est le
sentiment d'une permanence de quelque
chose qui
tienne beaucoup qui préserve bon et qui
manquera oui qui manquera parce que déjà
la longévité du règne et exceptionnelle
et puis alors moi j'ai jamais rencontré
personnellement mais de tout tous les
gens que je connais qui l'ont approché
m'ont dit qu'elle était très drôle vous
êtes beaucoup déguisé vous en prince
Charles français
puis malheureux quoi il a attendu très
longtemps pour étroit une autre photo
alors c'est vous lors d'une cérémonie
d'une des nombreuses cérémonies des
Césars que vous avez
présenter 10 je crois une dizaine de
fois vous avez été nommé une fois dans
la catégorie acteur mais vous ne l'avez
pas eu ce César est-ce que ça a été un
moment difficile un moment de regret
c'était pour votre rôle si moi ce
Kennedy oui c'était pour l'homme est une
femme comme les autres ben non en fait
j'étais dans la situation paradoxale de
de remettre des prix et puis d'être
nommé moi-même donc en fait je l'ai
plutôt échappé belle parce que j'aurais
dû faire un discours de remerciement
ou pas voilà j'avais quand même préparé
mon discours de remerciement et ben je
l'ai infligé au public puisqu'il était
prêt j'ai travaillé pour rien donc j'ai
quand même fait mon mon discours non
mais j'étais très heureux de que c'est
Jacques Villeret qu'il avait eu pour la
contrebasse une dernière photo pour vous
alors on vous voit avec
plusieurs militants et François Hollande
pour Solidarité Sida
association auprès de laquelle vous êtes
engagé depuis de très nombreuses années
ça a été une évidence dites-vous
aujourd'hui les progrès en matière de de
prévention de traitement sont un peu en
train de ralentir dans le monde entier
peut-être aussi à cause du covid est-ce
que ça fait partie des choses qui vous
inquiètent et ce que le fait que les
jeunes se disent bah il y a la
trithérapie donc on est un peu à l'abri
c'est moins grave est-ce que vous vous
sentez concerné par ça ça vous je me
sens concerné en tant que que président
d'honneur de cette association
Solidarité Sida que que voilà je suis
avec eux depuis vous avez raison ça fait
très longtemps mais d'abord on lâche pas
le morceau quand on s'est engagé dans un
truc comme ça c'est pas c'est pas une
cause éphémère
tant que tant que le problème va régler
oui on va continuer à continuer à
organiser ce festival à Solidays tous
les ans il y a plein d'initiatives avec
les associations africaines qu'on suit
[Musique]
et vous avez une énergie dans à chaque
fois dans des générations qui se
renouvellent puisque l'association a
presque 30 ans maintenant donc des mômes
qui viennent qui ont 18 20 ans qui
viennent donner une deux trois semaines
de leur vie pour aider à faire bouger
les choses donc croyez moi dans le monde
nous sommes c'est très important ce
genre d'initiative ça fait du bien une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
notre lieu Antoine de Caunes nous sommes
entourés de quatre statues qui
représentent chacune une vertu j'ai la
sagesse dans le dos vous avez la sagesse
dans le dos et alors n'y voyez aucun
signe c'est le la position de l'invité
c'est vous qui avez choisi tous les
invités
qui sont logés à la même enseigne vous
avez donc la sagesse ici la prudence ici
la justice et derrière moi les locaux
derrière moi
laquelle de ces vertus vous parlent le
plus ou à laquelle vous dans laquelle
vous reconnaissez peut-être
alors la prudence non
l'éloquence c'est fluctuant la sagesse
on la recherche toujours et c'est la
justice
je suis profond profondément animé par
un besoin de justice recherche de la
justice
voilà ce qui me
démonte ce qui me met en l'air c'est ce
que je peux voir entendre il y a les
exemples foisonnent en ce moment
je suis très assoiffé de justice alors
c'est une grande phrase c'est des grands
mots mais je pense que c'est de la
justice dépendent beaucoup d'autres
choses c'est un point d'équilibre absolu
et ce sera votre mot votre vertu à vous
merci merci Antoine de quoi d'avoir été
avec nous pour ce joli moment au sein du
retour c'est la merci et merci à vous de
nous avoir suivis comme chaque semaine à
très bientôt sur Public Sénat
et oui
[Musique]